this is a production of Cornell
University okay thank you so much Louie
thank you so much um for that very nice
introduction um so I wanted to talk to
you today about something a little bit
different um I am a social scientist and
trained in environmental political
science and this concept of polycentric
governance is really important for
addressing climate change and I've used
it in my work um from the local level to
the global level looking at climate
change in
agriculture okay so a little bit about
me um I really have worked been
fortunate to work um at many different
levels and this feeds into my interest
in polycentric governance um I studied
at Colby College in Maine and then W
went to work on National Environmental
Policy issues in Washington DC as an
environmental consultant I then W and
worked at the United Nations environment
program on the Montreal protocol and
then finished my PhD at Maryland went to
work for extension well first I worked
for Bard College but then I went to work
for extension in the Hudson Valley
working on climate change and
environmental issues in that region so a
regional level and then um in between
there I've worked on issues in Armenia
focused my dissertation there and then
came to Cornell where I've been here for
10 years I just moved to this department
last fall or
last mid year uh before that I was with
art Deano in the earth and Atmospheric
science
department okay okay so what I want to
talk to you about today has anyone heard
of polycentric
governance wow how cool introducing this
to you so I'm going to talk about this
idea this concept and then I'm going to
introduce climate smart
agriculture um then I'm going to focus
on my stakeholder engaged research the
work that I've done with Debbie over the
past two years it should be wrapping up
very soon um looking at the impacts of
climate change to agriculture in New
York state and then look at my extension
work uh from a local to National and
Global
level
so if you think about climate change I
just asked my students this on Tuesday
how many of you would say it is a global
problem or a national problem or a local
problem
Global local all of the above all of the
above but it is a transboundary
environmental issue meaning that the
emissions that we and every country emit
through many sectors including
agriculture uh once those greenhouse
gases go up in the atmosphere they don't
stay over the United States it's a
transboundary issue so we have to have a
mechanism for addressing that uh with
many countries all countries involved
and this idea of climate governance is
the diplomacy
mechanisms and response measures aimed
at steering social systems towards
preventing mitigating and adapting to
climate
change okay and so this idea of
polycentric governance came about in the
40s and 50s it's a system of governance
with many centers of decisionmaking
authority that are needed to cover the
full range of govern governance tasks
so you all said that climate change is a
global and a national and a local issue
so will it be effective if just the
United Nations in uh unfc is addressing
this
issue no it won't we have to have every
national government addressing this we
also have to have many actors involved
at all levels so the the political
scientist
who really brought this issue to the
Forefront was elanar Ostrom she was
trained in political science but
received a Nobel Prize um in 2009 for
her work the she won the new the prize
in economics and she researched how do
communities that manage common pool
resources manage them successfully and
she her work really debunked the tragedy
of the commons so she developed these
principles of institutional design and
she really worked on smaller common pool
resources this is for example um a
Commons that is a fishery in Italy or
Spain how do those fishermen work
together or Fisher women work together
to manage that resource and she said
that in order to be effective you have
to have several things in place clear
group identity um rules that match local
needs rules that are devised by those
that are um managing the
resource um sanctions that are known and
graduated and then a responsibility to
to link up that management with
different levels of um different
interconnected systems so if there's a
common pool resource in Italy it has to
be managed within that small area but
then Italy and then up to uh the UN
level so Ostrom then later in her life
thought about this idea of climate
change as a Global Commons issue and she
then did some work and published a
really famous Report with the World Bank
arguing that we can manage the best way
to manage climate change as a global
issue is through polycentric governance
she said said that single policies
adopted by one agency like a top- down
approach is not going to be effective
and that leaving just a United Nations
or even thinking about the United States
to solve the problem will result in Free
Rider issues like some countries aren't
going to do enough and instead a very a
polycentric approach is needed um which
has oversight at the local
National Regional level with many
actors and so this idea is that you can
think about a ripple going out or
interconnected circles concentric
circles of action so when I say many
modes and domains of action if you think
about who is addressing climate change
globally it's just not it's not just
National governments or the United
Nations businesses are involved NOS are
involved research institutions like
Cornell are involved and we're trying to
work with Farmers on the ground uh
individuals to get them involved she
Ostrum said this approach is more
diverse with greater emphasis on a
bottomup approach it emphasizes
self-organization site specific um work
experimentation learning and Trust so
there's a greater number of actors we've
seen this burining number of actors
involved I had the opportunity to take
Cornell to the cop 28 meeting in Dubai
there were 880,000 people there so you
can see how many people are working on
climate change some opposed to it who
were there um but that also leads to
Greater complexity and
Innovation but also the need for
coordination and information sharing so
I think this is a good metaphor and a
good theory for thinking about the work
that we do here at Cornell when we're
doing research and we're um as I am
doing extension work we are getting
individuals involved we have to focus on
site specific needs we have to have
experimentation working with our
partners and so I'm going to now turn to
how I've used this just to show you that
this was an initiative from the un
climate agency to start to track all of
this action and you can go to their
website and look for their Global
Climate action tracker um individual
countries cities companies investors
organizations are encouraged to start to
tell the UN about their
actions and I have Incorporated this
into my research so this was a report
that I worked on um that looked at
Global Food security and multi-level
governance just the idea that we for
going to address Global Food insecurity
we have these International agreements
the Paris agreement we have trade
agreements um that are setting these
goals but then they need to be
implemented at a national level and then
they need to be implemented on a local
level with Farmers or agricultural
producers have to be able to make change
so this is just an example of some of
the work that I've done with uh
interdisiplinary colleagues here at
Cornell that have used these ideas and
looked at non-state actors looked at
subnational governments um looked at how
politicians are tweeting about climate
change not not a government
agency so I'll turn now to a little bit
more about my stakeholder engaged
research stakeholder is a term that's
thrown out all the time and I think it's
important to Define it um Dan Decker
taught at Cornell for many years in
natural resources department he defined
it as a stakeholder is any citizen or
group potentially affected by or with a
vested interest in an issue a program an
action or a decision so we know through
research from many social scientists
that if we are designing an extension
program or we're developing decision
tools they are not going to be effective
unless we know what stakeholders
understand what they need how they're
going to use the tools or the
information and this is summarized well
by this quote by Bartels who says any
process to engage stakeholders around
the issue of climate change that fails
to systematically understand and
incorporate their views their values
beliefs and identities is likely to not
be
effective so um when I first came to
Cornell 10 years ago and worked with
many colleagues um including art Deano
and others here we thought about the
fact that we wanted to understand what
stakeholders knew about climate change
what Farmers understood and then develop
our decision support tools and our
extension programs and this is not just
a one-way process we really want input a
two-way process from those that are
going to use our
information so I'll explain how I've
used this with this concept of climate
smart agriculture how many of you have
heard of the term yeah I great that's
great so I would say this term it was
developed by the UN food and agriculture
organization about 10 12 years ago it's
come to much greater prominence now um
both globally many countries that have
developed their nationally determined
contributions to the Paris agreement
have included climate smart agriculture
for mitigation and adaptation and in the
United States um two years ago Biden
Administration announced they would have
a climate smart Commodities program to
funnel billions of dollars through
grants including one at Cornell with New
York state to Farmers to adopt climate
smart agriculture practices so I'm glad
you've heard of the term it's really a
three-pronged approach it focuses on
mitigation um sustainably increasing
food productivity and income and then
strengthening resilience or adaptation
so adaptation mitigation and increasing
food uction
sustainably so the work that I've done
at
Cornell over the past 10 years has used
that framework um as a starting point um
when I first came in 2017 I worked on a
meta analysis looking at us agriculture
stakeholder views and decisions on
climate change that was published in
wires climate change and then with a
postto David Lane and others including
colleagues from the Northeast climate
Hub we did conducted focus groups with
farmers in
Pennsylvania uh New York State and
Wisconsin to understand what are they
experiencing what are their views on
climate change and what actions are they
taking in general we found that farmers
are experience extreme weather extreme
weather events and they're more likely
to take action on their arms either to
mitigate or adapt if they've experienced
climate change
personally and they're more likely to to
be willing to adapt um many farmers are
still very skeptical of this human
causation of climate change so this
there is a need to keep um understanding
these views if they're changing over
time so with the climate smart farming
program at Cornell we also conducted
local interviews and captured videos of
farmers I love this quote from Tor
Ashner if you've met him he Farms about
a thousand acres of organic grain in
Newfield New York and when we
interviewed him a few years ago now he
said a normal season does not seem like
it happens anymore it's either really
dry or really wet it seems like when we
get rain it's
apocalyptic we got 5 Ines of rain in
about an hour and a half and I had a lot
of soil loss I can see the impact for
Generations what interestingly when we
talked with him about there's a a
wonderful map from the U National
Climate assessment that shows that the
Northeast region has seen a 55% increase
in extreme rainfall events so when we
are getting rain it's coming in these
heavy downpours he wasn't aware that
this was connected to climate change
this was a few years ago um he knew it
was happening on his farm and he felt
the impact of soil loss and erosion but
he didn't connect it to global climate
change so this is important to be
talking to Farmers and helping them make
these
connections so with funding from um
multi-state hatch project I conducted a
survey of New York State farmers with
colleagues including shaa alred who's
who's was at Cornell and now is at UNC
um and we conducted a random sample of
New York State farmers um we had I just
want to make the point that doing a
survey is very challenging to to do it
well and to be able to publish the work
it has to be very rigorous and connected
to the theory so you have to have uh a
research question that you want to
understand develop the survey questions
to try to ascertain data that will
answer that research question and then
you can't just um use a survey sample
from like sending it out with extension
to Farmers you can but that's not a uh
rigorous survey that is random sample so
we USDA is also very particular about
farmer data and they will not provide
you with contact names for Farmers um we
also have this concept of survey fatigue
we need to be really careful that we're
not overs serving the farmers that we're
working with so we actually had to
purchase a sample through a magazine
that actually goes to Farmers across the
United States and they gave us very
accurate and updated um Farmers um
including their address phone and email
we then developed we didn't have funding
to do a mailed survey so we used the
Cornell uh qualtrix tool we did an
online survey that was sent out to 3,400
Farmers we got a response completion of
524 surveys which is a response rate of
15% which is really high for survey work
um then we did a non-response survey
with 26 completions to make sure that
the responses we were getting were not
biased and we found through our
non-response survey that they were were
were not so what did we find well first
of all we asked questions about how
Farmers viewed climate change the
actions they were taking to mitigate and
adapt to climate change whether they
were taking those actions because of
climate change or just because they
were adopting no till because it's a
good practice to adopt and then we asked
them several questions about decision
tools and precision
Agriculture and we found that 83% of the
farmers surveyed have experienced
extreme weather events that affected
their Farm in the past five years and
57% of farmers felt they did not have
the financial capacity or the capacity
to address climate change so there is a
real need for providing support and
funding to Farmers we also found that
68% of the farmers that responded were
concerned or very concerned about
drought 64% were concerned or very
concerned about extreme
precipitation for adaptation practices
you can see what they were
utilizing for decision tools
interestingly 63% of those we asked were
not using any apps or smartphones or
mobile devices to inform their
management decisions this was a few
years ago now but um I think this is
probably you know the large farmers in
New York state are probably using
Precision Agriculture and they're
working with Consultants the smaller and
medium size farmers they may be using
weather apps but they're not using more
in-depth decision tools the barriers we
found were uh the top three responses
were I'm not aware of these tools
they're too costly or they don't apply
to my
farm and another uh bit of information
we asked about specific resources they
were using uh they
were uh some were using the US drought
monitor uh the Farmers
Almanac and the weather channel was the
biggest s uh tool they were using um and
farmers of the farmers who were not
using tools who were interested they
were interested in the climate smart
Farming tools and the northeast regional
climate Center
data so I want to do a small shout out
to Louie um through philli I've made a
connection in the hallway being upstairs
on the 10th floor which is awesome and
realized um that we have this data from
this Statewide survey that we haven't
published yet and Louie has uh conducted
interviews with Farms um and an started
to analyze them and has funding to do a
survey in New York and we can do what's
called a mixed method analysis combine
these data sets and have a richer um
analysis and understanding of how
farmers are thinking about farm
digitization and
experimentation so now I want to quickly
talk about the New York State climate
impacts assessment project that I've
worked on with Debbie Aller and several
other faculty at Cornell and other
organizations um this has been a hugely
in-depth project we're super excited
it's coming to an end soon it should be
published very soon if you have worked
with climate change in New York state
you know that the previous assessment
was the clim a report and I use that all
the time in my work it's very it's an
analogous to the National Climate
assessment but for New York State or the
ipcc assessments that are done for a
global level so this was the task of our
chapter was to look at how climate
impacts the agriculture sector since the
last report and we used a really
rigorous methodology these were our
participants we had a very strong
advisory committee that read the drafts
and
participated and the climate change data
was updated by Columbia
University um so you can see here these
are the projected annual average
temperature in New York state um during
the 20th 21st century um historical
observation since 1901 average
temperatures in New York state have
increased by 2.5 degrees
Fahrenheit um and the projections for
the future really depend on the
emissions that we and everyone around
the globe um emits so there's a range
there but temperatures could rise
between five an additional 5 to 11
degrees Fahrenheit by the 2080s which
would really
be catastrophic so we need to address
try to bring those emissions down you
can see the data for
precipitation um total annual
precipitation in New York state has
increased from 1901 to
2022 and the fastest increase has
occurred since the early
1980s and we will in with projections we
will see an increase of between 9 to 12%
by the 2080s you know this is a blessing
and a curse if you think think about the
South Western United States my colleague
Toby Al in Earth and Atmospheric science
has studied Mega droughts and where
agriculture much of it is produced in
Southern California those areas are
going to be much much more dry in the
future so we uh are going to have water
in New York state but the way that we
receive that water is very challenging
for Farmers it comes in these heavy
rainfall events
and we also know that the plant
hardiness zones for New York State and
the entire country have changed we're
seeing warmer Winters and longer growing
seasons and changes in plant hardiness
zones that have shifted across the
Northeast if you're interested you can
look up the plant hardiness zone maps
from
USDA so the key findings are that
there's five key findings from this
impacts assessment um the key findings I
won't into detail you can read it maybe
we'll send it around to the department
when it comes out um the most severe
impacts are extreme precipitation
short-term drought heat stress warmer
Winters late spring freeze increased
press pressure and production costs the
second finding is that climate change is
a threat multiplier we did a lot of work
interviewing Farmers talking to our
advisory committee and climate change
may not be the number one challenge
they're facing they may be facing labor
shortages or production costs Rising but
climate change makes all these other
issues it exacerbates these
stressors um the third key finding is
that we see that farmers and a
stakeholders show awareness and
acknowledgement of climate change
impacts on agriculture this is really a
big I think shift that I've seen in the
last 10 years of my work here
um key finding four farmers are
implementing and investing in
practices um but they need support and
funding and information to make those
changes and the fifth key finding is
that enhancing technical support
financial assistance and research is
critical for Farmers we also conducted
um really interesting case
studies and you can see this wonderful
quote from a local Dairy it's hard to
invest in the farm when there's so much
uncertainty about whether dairy prices
will break even
um and we this is a challenge we saw
many small farms across the hills and
now there are only three Farms left in
this
Valley so in the last couple of minutes
I'll turn to my work on extension
Outreach and education um I've talked
about this before in for this group
group so I won't uh spend time but uh we
developed a climate smart farming
website and tools that you can play
around with they're free for any farmer
from the Northeast um in the Northeast
from Maine to West Virginia and farmers
can enter specific data about their
Farms we also are based on this concept
of climate smart agriculture so see
these are some of the tools that we have
the growing degree day calcul is shown
here it's it can go back in time um you
can change the growing degree day base
that is built for right now for corn
showing corn and it will show a farmer
in the season where they are with their
crop capturing growing degre day
accumulation units or they can look at
past seasons and see how that has
changed and make really management
decisions this is our extension team
including Candace hbert who's just
joined Johannes and I and art Deano and
Debbie and I've done a lot of work um I
would like to do more um but I've done
work going out to Farms with our
extension team um most recently we were
at the a society Forum in Syracuse with
our display and getting youth to answer
a survey and then I was in Albany on
Monday um a lot of interest in climate
smart farming this is another program
that I'm running this spring with the
USDA climate Hub it is a dairy climate
adaptation fellowship program I love
this program it's super interesting we
are training pairs of Da Farmers with an
advisor and it's a nine-week training
program and then we're going to do field
events and they're going to develop an
adaptation and mitigation plan for their
farm this
year another program that I developed
here at Cornell is the CL Cornell
climate stewards program it's modeled
after the Master Gardener program we've
had Farmers take the training and do a
project so they're they're not only just
getting trained on climate science and
impacts but they agree to do a project
in their community so far we've trained
94 climate stewards from 15 counties
including those extension Educators from
out in the counties and lastly I'm now
working with Johannes and Candace on
this AI climate Institute I hope we can
share more information about it over the
next five years the idea is that Ai and
machine learning and large amounts of
data can improve decision tools and
understanding and decision making of
policy makers and Farmers to be able to
better address and solve climate change
by improving mitigation and adaptation
so Candace and I and johanes um we are
working on the stakeholder assessment
component so we'll be conducting focus
groups and surveys with farmers and
policy makers about Ai and climate smart
agriculture we're already out doing
training as we get more information and
we're planning to do for example a 4 AG
career explow activity this summer and
we're doing
Outreach I guess the final thing I'll
say is that I've worked on this issue
from the local to the global level I've
been very fortunate to lead Cornell's
delegation to the cop since cup 21 and I
um get a badge every for the past five
years from the government of Armenia so
I can go in the a um agriculture
negotiations really see how the
countries are working on this issue what
they care about and help with the
negotiations um this year was in Dubai
um we had several students and faculty
go with us I was part of an event on
climate smart agriculture we saw John KY
walk by and said hey we're from
Cornell um and this is the agriculture
negotiations so I believe it's really
important to be at this Global level
with our climate smart agriculture
research so these are key takeaways
stakeholder engagement is key extension
education is critical training and
Outreach we won't get Farmers to adopt
practices um without training them and
policy engagement is key and I would end
by saying climate change affects
everything and begins with each of us
and what we can do in our communities
this is my son Robert he's now a
freshman at Cornell and he's studying
viticulture yay so you might have him in
your classes and
um get involved just like
ripples um spread out when dropped in
the water the actions of individuals can
have far-reaching
effects so thank you yeah Judy
um across state um you and there's a
variety of farming practices across New
York State caring fr uh you you separate
them out in any way and if you did would
you think that they have a different
response to some of your
questions that's a great question for
the focus group research we did we did a
focus group is a group interview and you
want to have like-minded people in the
room you want to have about a Max of 10
farmers in a room and we did have
separate commodity groups so we had a
focus group with vegetable Growers Dairy
fruit and vegetable so that data was
what that we got was based on different
commodity groups the survey that I did
of New York State farmers we we asked
them what they're growing and what their
commodity was but we didn't
differentiate the practices
out but that could be something that we
think of in the
future thank
you yeah hi I'm wondering in the results
of from your survey have you observed a
significant a significant difference of
climate impact across different um
practices for example um a for or crop
um like that yeah that's a great
question the survey that um I did in New
York state we didn't we didn't ask them
that um
it was an online survey and we had to be
really careful about limiting the number
of questions um that could be certainly
something we think about for the future
um hopefully with Louie we're doing a
survey maybe a smaller scale in New York
state or with Candace we could think
about that thank
you Al I have a question sort of follow
from Jes your takeaway number for you
have the this totally about what their
practices are and it sounds like you
have sort of partitioned out user groups
with the tools that they're using the
best BS bmps whatever it happens to be
have you actually done that at this
point where you can sort of say these
are the things that they're doing and
then can that be linked to effects and
implications of that kind of stuff no
but interestingly I I took that slide
out but um Debbie and I worked hard in
the New York State climate impact
assessment the nerta really wanted in
this impacts assessment to have a focus
on adaptation not only understanding the
impacts but what are the adaptations
that we can recommend so with our team
we came up with a table that is
differentiated so we know that the
climate impacts to dairy or vegetable
Growers are different and they're also
different based on the region where you
are so they're very particular um so the
table has
suggested adaptations for dairy for
field crops for fruit for aquaculture
and that is something that we could
follow up with and see you know B sector
which our Farmers really adopting these
practices because of climate impacts are
they just adopting them because they're
good practices and and then
with folks like Matt Ryan or others you
know doing long-term studies to measure
the effectiveness on agriculture systems
would be really
important did that answer your question
did sort of I my immediate response to
that is that in since I'd be more on the
Louis end of the spectrum or saying
rather than say this is your research
these guys are doing research on their
Farms yeah intentionally or not yes
those are the people that should be
teaching we shouldn't be telling what
you should do you should basically use
these as demonstrations oh yes that's a
great idea research becomes the Grower's
research not Cornell's research sure yep
uh that's kind of what we're doing with
the dairy climate adaptation Fellowship
um there's four of those programs
running right now we are running the
dairy one but we're partnering with it's
a peer training mod model we're
partnering a farmer with a consultant
and then they're going to go out and
actually do develop an implementation
plan for their farm and they have to
share what they're doing with us and
with other
farmers and we're we're it just seems
that you've got a natural experiment
going on yeah that we could take
advantage of that's a great Point yeah
yeah thank
you yeah I said I would only ask easy
questions an easy question actually how
does this information get back to the
legislature is there a structural is
there a structural relation in which all
this information of the assessment is
presented legislature in the n in the
New York State climate assessment yeah
that um definitely will happen um this
was driven by New York state nerta
agency with um it was we were appointed
by Governor hokel um so there will there
is a similar mitigation work and we were
the adapt impacts and adaptation work so
I think there's going to be a stronger
effort to get the information out and
make sure it's used I was thinking that
certain regulations that might be in law
might need to be changed according
changing circumstances yes great Point
yeah what have you found is the planning
horiz for the farmers so if you only
plan for three or four years you might
react very differently to the
recommendations than it plan for 20 30
years that's a great point I think
Debbie did some interviews with grape
Growers and D do you want to chime in we
know that perennial crops those farmers
are much more aware of climate impacts
yeah certainly areas by commodity and a
big part of it is how much um does an
individual farmer experience the impact
of climate change
and a big part is the financial side of
things the ability of a farmer to
actually have the financial capacity to
implement adaptation practices so
certain practices that can be adopted by
perennial Fruit Growers and the costs
around those for example like wi
machines which are more than like
$30,000 for a single wi machine that's a
huge upfront investment by the farmers
the ability for them to adopt practice
like that they need to have a long-term
vision for their Farm as well so it's a
really good question in terms of a
planning process and it varies Farm by
farm and
across
great yeah Harold yeah so I was
wondering and I really appreciate your
presentation in your report that there
are some negative Trends in agriculture
for example the dairy industry has
really gone to corn cided production
over foren your
forages and um and so cornide is much
less zillion that you know creates a lot
more runoff potential and things like
that does the report sort of address
some of those issues as well that
basically nutritionists are are
promoting one size production and it is
more efficient for you know in terms of
milk production but it's not very good
for climate adapt it's a negative
climate adaptation yeah is that being
addressed because those are some of the
tough questions that people don't want
to hear you know right we do we did try
really hard to look at um issues like
that um the complex issues between um
economics we had a whole section I'm not
I can't remember if we
actually had a struction on that
specific issue but I will keep it in
mind thank
you